je vous donne aujourd'hui 10 raisons de
venir acheter le Samsung Galaxy A54 à 54
5G bien évidemment c'est ce smartphone
non toi qui est dans cette boîte là
puisque c'est ce smartphone là un
smartphone extrêmement intéressant de
Samsung sera probablement le smartphone
le plus vendu en 2023 chez Samsung je
donne donc 10 bonnes raisons de venir
l'acheter et à la fin je vous donne 5
raisons de ne pas venir l'acheter 5
points négatifs et à la fin vous verrez
je vous donnerai mon arbitrage pour vous
dire si l'intéressant oui non quoi
comment vous êtes prêt à laisser partir
samsung vient de présenter donc son
nouveau Samsung Galaxy A54 5G mais
également d'autres smartphone ouvrir le
A54 5G on a également le A34 5G qui est
un peu moins speaké et je vous l'ai déjà
présenté dans une précédente vidéo et
puis vous avez également le A14 5G alors
pensez dès maintenant à venir vous
abonner parce que je vais tester tous
ces produits pour vous aider à venir
trouver le Samsung Galaxy a qui est fait
pour vous en 2023 on va commencer par le
plus haut de gamme le A54 5G qui joue le
dit et un smartphone intéressant mais
avant d'aller plus loin je donne 10
points 10 bonnes raisons de venir
l'acheter et une fois de plus à la fin
de la vidéo je donnerai 5 raisons de ne
pas venir l'acheter de car pas forcément
sacrément de ne pas venir l'acheter en
tout cas 5 points en dessous et après je
vous dirai si vous le coup oui non allez
vous êtes prêt on y va le premier point
c'est le multimédia c'est un smartphone
qui est extrêmement polyvalent pour
l'univers multimédia par multimédia
j'entends regardez des films des séries
sur Youtube bien évidemment la vidéo que
vous regardez tout de suite peut-être
pourriez-vous la regarder sur votre
a54-5g mais également des séries sur
Netflix prime vidéo et compagnie
pourquoi parce que vous avez un grand
écran de 6,4 pouces résolution Full HD+
ok c'est très très bien surtout c'est un
smartphone qui est extrêmement lumineux
ce qui fait que si vous voulez regarder
du contenu en extérieur vous n'aurez
aucun problème on va jusqu'à 1000 si si
regardez là je l'ai pas poussé à fond si
je le mets à fond franchement c'est très
très fort donc on va se mettre au milieu
et un point qui est vachement bien si
c'est que vous avez du son qui envoie
vraiment du pâté avec des haut-parleurs
stéréo Dolby Atmos ici on parle en
principal haut parleur de renfort mais
il y a quand même vachement de son
regardez je monte hop je vais me mettre
un peu plus loin vous voyez
alors pas évident de se rendre compte
comme ça mais il y a du son qui est
quand même en relativement fort il y a
de la puissance le son est bien maîtrisé
vous avez quand même un son qui est
assez rond pour un smartphone donc ça ça
marche vachement bien et une fois de
plus ça c'est un point très fort donc si
vous voulez regarder du contenu série
film multimédia YouTube TikTok Instagram
Real c'est compagnie et notamment de
Monsieur gros c'est très très chouette
et bien là-dessus vous serez absolument
pas déçu le deuxième point c'est que
c'est une bête au niveau de la
performance alors attention attention
pas autant pour elle aide certains
smartphones plus haut de gamme mais dans
le milieu de gamme c'est un smartphone
qui est très polyvalent qui permettra de
jouer à énormément de jeux regardez sur
asphalte 9 ici vous avez un taux de
rafraîchissement de 120 Hertz donc pour
le gaming c'est très très bien 120
images par seconde ça vous apporte donc
énormément de fluidité à leur bien
évidemment en expérience de gaming mais
également lorsque vous allez venir
scroller notamment sur Instagram et
compagnie ça apportera vraiment en
fluidité ça serait quand même vachement
bien il a un score sera tout de 510489
ce qui va le positionner juste en
dessous du riz demi pro plus 5g et pas
très très loin du à 52 s5g c'est un
smartphone qui fera vraiment la faire
dans le milieu de gamme pour faire
tourner énormément de jeux alors bien
évidemment pas les jeux qui vont
nécessiter le maximum de ressources mais
globalement il reste très polyvalent
donc pour lui vers gaming en terme de
performance vous avez vraiment ce qu'il
faut troisième point c'est l'autonomie
vous avez une très grosse batterie de
5000 maheur et c'est ce qu'on vient
attendre d'un smartphone dans le milieu
de gamme autant vous dire qu'il vous
tiendra une journée mille voir deux
jours et ça ça dépend une fois de plus
de vous et de vos usages donc on va pas
se stresser sur un smartphone qui
pourrait manquer d'autonomie donc ça
c'est plutôt rassurant ce qui nous amène
au 4e point et bien c'est la charge
rapide c'est un smartphone qui est
compatible chargé rapide 25 watts ce qui
est globalement suffisamment rapide sur
un smartphone milieu de gamme et qui
fera l'affaire le cinquième point sur
les mises à jour vous avez quatre en
deux mises à jour Android et 50 mise à
jour sécurité ça veut dire qu'il est
livré aujourd'hui avec Android 13 vous
aurez donc Android 14 Android 15 Android
16 Android 17 vous avez donc de quoi
venir regarder vers l'avenir donc sans
aucun problème plus 50 mise à jour
sécurité ce qui fait que quelque soit
les choses qui pourraient arriver
pendant au moins quatre ans voir 5 ans
vous êtes tranquille sixième point c'est
les photos ça smartphone qui est très
polyvalent qui conviendra parfaitement
bien pour faire une bonne photo alors
vous avez ici un grand angle de 50
mégapixels un ultra grand angle de 8
mégapixels et une caméra Makro de
mégapixels sans oublier une caméra de
selfie de 16 mégapixels et les photos
ont fait avec le grand angle sont juste
bien faites marche très bien regardez
ici une station-service à Paris place de
la Liberté ou le ciel ressort très bien
par contre comme on n'est pas sur une
gamme S vous voyez ça va moins bien
venir traiter ici la statue mais
globalement vous avez quand même rendu
photographique qui est correct grand
angle ultra grand angle et après on
vient se rapprocher avec un zoom
numérique et plus vous vous rapprochez
plus vous avez de bruit ça c'est normal
là je vous ai pris la photo il y a
aucune retouche ici c'est complètement
naturel je suis dans un rayon de soleil
dans l'ouverture d'une porte et voyez le
rendu est très bien je ne suis pas cramé
à l'intérieur ça marche aussi et au
niveau de la gestion de haute lumière
c'est plutôt pas mal c'est très sombre
ici on voit bien ici ça sort quand même
pas trop mal au fond et après on passe
sur l'ultra grand-angle et on vient se
rapprocher jusqu'à zoom optique x 10
regardez ici le ciel est préservé les
détails sont bons ultra grand-angle
fonctionne très bien aussi et après on
peut venir zoomer un petit peu pareil
ici vous voyez les détails au niveau du
ciel on voit bien le théâtre ultra
grand-angle ça marche bien et après on
vient zoomer le mode portrait fonctionne
aussi très très bien avec un beau
détourage un fou derrière plan qui est
quand même vachement bien maîtrisé quel
que soit la situation soleil pas soleil
pas de problème de votre lumière ici
regardez ici pas de souci ça fonctionne
bien alors si vous venez vraiment
chercher la petite bête vous allez la
trouver notamment au niveau du soleil
ici dans le ciel mais sinon globalement
le taf est fait la caméra selfie un
petit peu en dessous un peu plus terne
un peu moins brillante sur les
contre-jour ça fonctionne c'est pas la
meilleure caméra selfie du monde mais
une fois de plus on est sur un
smartphone un tarif plus maîtriser le
mode nourriture aussi est correct et
fonctionne quand même plutôt pas trop
mal le mode portrait de nuit est pas
mauvais mais voyez il va avoir un tout
petit peu de mal sur les côtés au niveau
du détourage même s'il est pas trop mal
fait et le rendu ici est pas
complètement optimal photo nu c'est
plutôt sympa attention il y a un petit
peu de bruit sur les côtés ce qui n'est
pas non plus surprenant c'est un peu la
limite c'est le bruit qu'on pourra venir
retrouver ici l'ultra grand-angle on
oublie la nuit et après on peut venir se
rapprocher mais une fois de plus le
résultat sera pas optimal sinon
globalement les photos de nuit sont
plutôt sympa même dans une rue comme ça
ça marche bien il y a une belle ambiance
très jolie ici la limite ça va être les
lentilles au niveau du Lens flair si
vous venez shooter des Lumières à ses
proches mais sinon le rendu quand même
vachement sympa voilà dans différents
endroits avec différentes ambiances 7e
point c'est le design qui est hérité de
une gamme S S23 avec regarder vraiment
ce bloc photo qui vient vraiment
ressembler au Galaxy S23 un design qui
est très élégant et pour les non avertis
c'est pas évident de venir différencier
le milieu de gamme chez Samsung du haut
de gamme chez Samsung donc on a vraiment
une uniformité au niveau de la gamme je
trouve très très bien avec juste les
optiques qui vont venir ressortir ici un
dos en verre sans oublier le capteur
d'empreinte digitale qui déverrouille
extrêmement bien et ça c'est chouette le
8e point ça va être les techno que vous
avez à l'intérieur il est très actuel
avec bien évidemment une carte SIM
également sans oublier du wifi 6 donc si
vous voulez une bonne connexion rapide à
la maison en wifi c'est bien votre
smartphone ici peut l'accepter et ça
c'est chouette le 9e point c'est un
smartphone qui va être
réside à l'avant et
à la bien et en plus de ça il est
certifié résistant à l'eau et à la
poussière avec une certification
IP67 dixième point ayant des moins ça va
être l'expérience logiciel vous êtes sur
One URI qui est une très très bonne
expérience signée Samsung que
personnellement j'adore très simple très
lisible très clair on trouve tout tout
très très rapidement au niveau de la
gestion de votre écran de l'audio de
tout ce que vous voulez bref il y a
beaucoup beaucoup d'options c'est clair
c'est lisible ça marche bien
personnellement gros coup de coeur ici
bon alors maintenant qu'on a vu les 10
points qui sont les 10 bonnes raisons de
venir l'acheter il y a quelques points
qui sont un petit peu en dessous bien
évidemment on est sur un smartphone
milieu de gamme on va pas tout avoir
voici donc les cinq points qui sont en
dessous par rapport à ce smartphone le
premier point c'est que vous n'avez pas
de téléobjectif donc si vous êtes
amoureux de la photo et bien il faudra
vous contenter du Grand Angle ultra
grand-angle et de la macro et d'un zoom
numérique ce qui viendra dégrader un
petit peu la qualité photo si vous
voulez venir zoomer donc ici ça peut
être un peu limitatif une fois de plus
la gamme photo c'est la gamme S donc il
va falloir débourser un peu plus
d'argent mais le tarif on en parle dans
quelques instants le deuxième point qui
est un peu en dessous c'est la Macron
alors ils nous ont mis trois capteurs
parce qu'il faut mettre trois capteurs
et qu'aujourd'hui c'est une question de
marketing au niveau des marques mais
très honnêtement un capteur de 2
mégapixels c'est pas fou il regardait le
rendu alors on peut essayer de venir
shooter mais voilà c'est pas beau c'est
pas précis les couleurs sont pas
extraordinaires le piqué est pas bon
bref le rendu au niveau de la macro
n'est pas extraordinaire c'est compliqué
de venir trouver la bonne distance et
voyez une fois de plus bon voilà c'est
ni fait ni à faire dernier point qui
importe c'est que vous n'avez pas la
dernière génération de cornigoria glace
c'est le Corning Gorillaz victus plus
non vous l'avez pas vous êtes ici sur un
5 alors ce qui est bien parce que ça va
quand même venir certifier que votre
smartphone va pas craindre au niveau des
quelques micro rayures et compagnies
mais bon on n'est pas sur la dernière
génération de la même manière on n'est
pas sur une certification
IP68 au niveau de l'étanchéité vous me
direz on est sur un smart phone au
milieu de gamme c'est déjà bien qu'il y
a encore une Gorillaz 5 c'est déjà bien
que les certifications il fait 77 mais
bon ça peut certainement être un tout
petit peu limitatif un tout petit peu le
quatrième point c'est que c'est un
smartphone qui est compatible charge
rapide 25 watts mais uniquement 25 watts
alors on sait souvent que chez Samsung
ils vont pas nous mettre des charges
extrêmement rapides 125 watts 67 watts
non pas 65 watts 25 watts uniquement il
va falloir prendre votre mal impatience
et le cinquième point négatif c'est que
votre bloc de charge n'est pas inclus
vous avez une toute petite boîte pas de
bloc de charge donc si vous n'avez pas
de bloc de charge 25W et que vous voulez
de la recharge rapide signé Samsung et
bien il va falloir venir débourser un
peu plus d'argent pour faire
l'acquisition d'un bloc de charge 25
watts compatible avec ce smartphone
alors ce Samsung Galaxy A54 5G est-ce
qu'il est intéressant est-ce qu'il
fonctionne bien oui non quoi comment
voici mon retour d'expérience alors
personnellement je l'aime bien je l'aime
bien pourquoi parce que c'est un
smartphone que je trouve bien positionné
qui a l'expérience Samsung qui est dans
l'écosystème Samsung donc si vous voulez
des écouteurs si vous voulez une montre
Samsung et bien vous aurez tout qui rate
très très bien ici donc les planètes
viennent vraiment s'aligner l'expérience
logiciel est bonne on a suffisamment de
performances on a une grosse batterie on
a une belle autonomie on a un appareil
photo grand angle qui est correct qui
fonctionnera très bien on a donc tous
les ingrédients pour avoir un smartphone
milieu de gamme qui fonctionnera bien et
qui sera répondre 90% de vos attentes
sans aucun problème et quelques points
un peu en dessous que je vous ai cités
sont pas nécessairement gravissi toute
façon un capteur macro 2 mégapixels ne
sert à rien il ne servira jamais à rien
mais pour tout le reste c'est un
smartphone que j'aime bien et que je
viens vous recommander s'il vous
intéresse alors parlons du tarif le
tarif est ici c'est un smartphone qui
coûte et ouais il est pas gratos on s'en
doutera la modique somme version 8 Go de
RAM 128 Go de stockage 499 euros pour
venir l'acheter dans cette configuration
et 8 256 549 je vous recommande la
version 828 on est un peu en dessous de
500 euros ça reste quand même beaucoup
d'argent mais comme on vient stocker
beaucoup dans le Cloud 128 Go de
stockage pour moi ça fera largement
l'affaire et vous n'aurez pas de
problème ici et en plus de ça ce qui est
vachement bien c'est que vous avez une
offre de lancement jusqu'au 30 avril
2023 vous avez des Samsung Galaxy buds 2
qui sont offert avec donc si vous n'avez
pas d'écouteur et que vous voulez une
expérience qui est cool et bien vous
aurez vos écouteurs signés Samsung
compatibles et bien qui seront offerts
avec une fois de plus je vous mets un
lien en bas dans la description comme ça
au moins il y a pas de mauvaise surprise
dites-moi donc ce que vous en pensez
est-ce que c'est un smartphone qui
pourrait vous plaire oui non tout ça
quoi comment alors si vous avez déjà
Samsung Galaxy a53 de l'année dernière
devenez pas changer il reste très actuel
il va très bien de la même manière si
vous avez un A52 et qu'il convient bien
gardez-le il ne faut pas venir changer
ses produits électroniques trop
régulièrement mais si vous voulez vous
faire plaisir si vous avez un smartphone
qui est trop vieux ou si votre
smartphone est cassé plus fonctionnel et
bien le Galaxy A54 sera vous satisfaire
c'est un très joli produit
personnellement je l'aime bien dites-moi
donc ce que vous en pensez en bas dans
les commentaires et puis nous on se
retrouve très bientôt pour parler bien
évidemment du à 34 5g et également du
A14 5g et ça c'est chouette je vous
embrasse prenez soin de vous et à très
bientôt Ciao
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]